all right so mando is done the
mandalorian has wrapped and I watched
the rest of it it's gonna be some
spoiler ish things in here we all know
about baby Yoda at this point right so
there is that I also talked about the
first four episodes on video I was doing
videos on Mandalorian week-to-week and
then at a point I realized a lot of you
were right because I started bitching
about the fact it's like why are they so
episodic the episodes are a bit more
episodic than I thought I saw some
people in the comments section like it's
supposed to be that and after the
episode titled gunslinger I was like
yeah it's supposed to totally be like
that I can only compare it to Batman the
Animated Series one of the greatest
animated series of all time and if you
look at it's very episodic every episode
is the half hour Batman episode we have
today
what's the adventure this week probably
for the most part unlinked to last
week's episode and that's more or less
with some differences involved but more
or less what Mandalorian is like and
after the gunslinger episode I was like
I'm not doing a video on this week's
gunslinger episode I'm just gonna binge
the Mandalorian in the last three
episodes which was a great call but if
you don't know what the Mandalorian is
it's a series on Disney Plus it's eight
episodes long and it follows a
Mandalorian who picks up a package of
baby Yoda yeah all the memes you've seen
the memes baby Yoda what a way to close
out the decade give us the cutest thing
of the decade and then Mandalorian takes
us baby Yoda with him along on these
adventures the remnants of the now
crumbled Empire they want baby Yoda
Amanda's just not giving him up which
really makes the Mandalorian my Firefly
fix that I've been missing for a while
you have your protagonist he's a little
rough around the edges he has a job he
has a code the code they live by
directly conflicts with their own moral
compass so what to do and that's when
they find out they're not exactly as
rough as they maybe thought they were
which is very Star Wars also very Malcom
Reynolds in both cases they know if they
just turn in this child the hell that's
being rained down in their world it'll
probably go away but they both know it's
just wrong I love that when it clicked
with me like this is Firefly kind of
different but kinda made me love it even
more because also a Mandalorian hits a
bit of a Goldilocks zone Disney Star
Wars has been trying to hit for a while
how do we update Star Wars to appeal to
a new generation when Star Wars is also
something that their parents and their
parents parents also love you have to
update it in certain parts and all the
right ways but also keep the fundamental
lessons and the basics the same and I
think Mandalorian actually did it real
well it has that grit and tone that I
felt rogue one
actually did a good job at bringing in
two Star Wars it also has a good
character journey with the Mandalorian
like I said someone who finds out that
maybe they're not as rough around the
reference but maybe they're not as
shitty as they thought they were deep
down they're a good person also
Mandalorians totally an underdog I mean
he's a badass but among the other
Mandalorians you can tell is like he's
not the biggest of the Mandalorians but
he's our guy he's us if we were a
Mandalorian it is funny okay this is
kind of spoilery territory but it is
funny that baby Yoda does things like
force healing is a thing which I do
humor the idea that Mandalorian was
created to show force heals so then
people would by force heal in the rise
of Skywalker not gonna talk about it too
much because this is a video on
Mandalorian not the ability of force
heal but since force heal is in the
Mandalorian in the Clone Wars that any
Jedi die because if you send Jedi out
there in Paris one Jedi gets wounded the
other one could just heal him no Jedi
die in fact you can heal clone troopers
as well everyone could have healed
qui-gon he's just a Padawan true but
he's trained longer than Rey or baby
Yoda I imagine he would know or know of
the ability also Anakin Skywalker did
leave the Jedi Order because he needed
to go somewhere that had the ability to
stop people from dying and heal them is
it possible to learn this power only
from a Jedi but that player story was
pretty sick huh join me do it
logistically it's not about who does the
force Hills the fact that force heals
now at back the Mandalorians actually
intense and exciting and seen Stewart
has that's a couple sweet shootouts
Episode three is a crazy good episode
three is one of the things where I'm
like this is cinema quality here the
visual effects in this show I'm like
this is a movie I'll give Disney that
they were like this is gonna the special
effects it's gonna feel like a movie
we're gonna put that kind of budget into
it I was like ah [ __ ] well so Wow
okay just in terms of entertainment the
Star Wars world is so big that a series
it really lends itself to is serious
Rises Skywalker just came out what are
people quoting from Star Wars two things
this is the way and I have spoken those
of them those are the two quotes just
flying around the internet and baby oda
memes it's all come from Mandalorian I
feel like Mandalorian is a natural
progression of Star Wars back in the day
it was space Wizards now I'm just I'm a
little more interested in the criminal
underworld which is really what they
wanted to do with solo but I didn't get
that from solo solo just felt like less
the same arc I saw from Han Solo in a
new
with Mandalorian it does sound the same
but it is executed in a different way in
a way that's actually more in line with
Firefly which was a throwback to Star
Wars which now I just find ironic in all
the right ways but also entertaining in
all the right way so folks wouldn't
trying to say is Mandalorian is one of
those shows that I love to binge and I'm
glad i binge the last three episodes
when season 2 happens which it well I'm
just gonna binge that show when it's all
out because they just love binging shows
like this the Star Wars underworld is
something I've always enjoyed I've
always liked I've only gotten glimpses
of it though this is the show that lets
you live in it for a while it has good
grit but also personality you're not
prepared for how much personality shines
through that helmet good supporting
characters and yes there is a reason
baby Yoda has just been trending so much
lately if you're a fan of Star Wars
and/or Firefly I think you'll dig
Mandalorian if you haven't seen it by
now
I'm actually kind of surprised you
should check it out if you don't want to
support the Disney Empire I got it if
you know someone who does have Disney
Plus though go over and binge this with
them think you'll enjoy it I won't spoil
this but I will say the end of the last
episode does have a pretty sweet Easter
Egg Easter Egg reveal point is one of
the things that audibly said out loud
like oh [ __ ] it's pretty sweet I'd like
to see where they're going with that so
Mandalorian season 1 have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]